madame mademoiselle monsieur bonsoir
les italiens vont élire leurs députés le
20 juin une date qui peut devenir
historique dans la mesure où elle
marquerait la victoire décisive du parti
communiste italien historique pour
l'italie mais aussi pour les démocraties
occidentales à commencer par sa plus
proche voisine
la france et la fête du 1er mai qui peut
d'ores et déjà être considérée comme
l'ouverture de la campagne électorale
dans la péninsule
à voir et entendre ce qui s'est passé
samedi à turin
on peut avoir une idée de la puissance
de la machine qui s'est mise en marche
avec comme objectif la victoire
électorale
plus avant dans ce journal nous vous
présenterons l'interview exclusive
d'hommes berthod agnelli le
vice-président de fiat dont les usines
principales sont justement à turin
devant la perspective d'une victoire
électorale des communistes et de leur
arrivée au pouvoir
l'un des patrons de la première firme
industrielle italienne ne perd pas lui
vous vous en rendrez compte son sang
froid
la hausse des prix a été encore plus
vive en mars que je vous l'avais annoncé
la semaine dernière l'institut national
de la statistique a complété ses calculs
ce n'est plus 0 9%
c'est 1% un petit dixième qui pèse
psychologiquement son poids est
davantage même 1,1 pour cent en janvier
1% en mars
ce n'est plus un accident ce peut être
le début d'une accélération durable
on comprend que puisse paraître choquant
dans de telles conditions
'l'annonce d'une hausse prochaine du
prix des carburants + 5 % à la mi mai
annonce parue dans certains journaux
aujourd'hui et qui correspond troppo
désir de groupes pétroliers pour ne pas
ressembler à une pression sur le pouvoir
la hausse des prix de détail préoccupe
déjà assez comme cela le ministre des
finances nous allons le voir pour qu'il
tente de différer toute augmentation qui
ne s'imposeraient pas alors j'ai
confirmé en voyant le spectacle où les
exposants de la foire de paris
la reprise économique était maintenant
général est que notre taux de croissance
en 1976 sera sans doute supérieur à
celui que nous avions près en revanche
il est certain que nous avons quelques
difficultés en matière de prix nous
avons eu un effet comme vous le savez un
mois de janvier qui a été mauvais mois
de février qui a été meilleur que moi de
mars paraît s'annoncer assez mauvais une
connaissons encore que l' indice
parisien du mois de mars tout en étant
l' indice national des prix à la fin de
la semaine ou début de semaine prochaine
mais il est certain que aussi bien sur
les prix des produits alimentaires que
sur celui des services que sur les prix
des produits manufacturés
nous avons à l'heure actuelle un certain
nombre de facteurs de hausse n est pas
un peu la conséquence de la reprise
cette forte inflation est effectivement
une des conséquences de la reprise de
même que le léger déséquilibre du
commerce extérieur et c'est pourquoi je
pense que ce mécanisme n'est que
provisoire et que je connaîtrais
ça définitif du premier trimestre c'est
à dire au début de la semaine prochaine
j'en tire l ensemble les conclusions qui
s'imposent en reconduction des régimes
de prix et pour les mesures destinées à
combattre l'inflation
la nouvelle est tombée à 12h31
le tribunal de commerce de paris a
décidé la liquidation de biens des
sociétés qui exploitent hellip depuis la
fin de la grande crise de 1973
ainsi personne aucun groupe industriel
français ou étrangers ne sera ne sera
présenté pour tenter de relancer une
affaire qui gérait avec rigueur et
compétence aurait pu survie quel gâchis
et on conçoit l'amertume des
travailleurs de leap qui semble avoir
reçu le coup de grâce
fin décembre 75
rien ne va plus entre le pdg de l'ip et
son conseil d'administration il y à des
difficultés de trésorerie
claude neuschwander réussit à débloquer
16 millions par les banques les
actionnaires les pouvoirs publics
et pourtant le 20 février le conseil
d'administration le contrainte à
démissionner claude neuschwander quitte
un poste qu'il occupe depuis mars 74
on lui reproche de graves erreurs de
gestion pour les syndicats c'est un
règlement de compte politique
on a démissionné le vendeur distille
parce qu'il est un patron de gauche la
semaine suivante est nommé le nouveau
pdg jean sargueil 56 ans l homme calme
peu expansif l'aventuré humaine des
ouvriers de l'ip le passionne un mois
plus tard le 5 avril jean sargueil
annonce
l'ip est en cessation de paiement il
s'explique
15 millions de déficit en 75 un stock
d'invendus de plus de 41 millions l'ips
dit il est fait pour fabriquer 1
millions de montres
il est impossible d'en écouler autant
sur le marché français très avril jean
sargueil dépose le bilan de la société
au tribunal de commerce de paris
24 avril épisode tragique
jean sargueil meurt d'une crise
cardiaque on se souviendra longtemps des
paroles du dernier pdg de l'ip
je n'ai jamais vu autant de haine autour
d'une entreprise aujourd'hui le tribunal
de commerce de paris prononcé cette fois
la liquidation définitive de l'ip et
désigne deux syndics et un juge
commissaire
sur place un palente l'atmosphère est
tendue et les léguer syndicaux sont
mobilisés nous sommes en occupation de
fête déclaré l'un d'entre eux nous
n'accepterons aucune solution qui ne
passe pas par le rayon bouchage des 900
employés de l'entreprise
pour nous c'est une décision de justice
qui continue d'aggraver la situation et
nous rappelons par la même occasion
l'écrasante responsabilité des pouvoirs
publics en la matière est-ce qu'ils
laisseront se dérouler un processus qui
amène à la disparition de l'entreprise
complète c'est-à-dire la disparition des
biens de l'entreprise ou bien est-ce
qu'ils favoriseront une la création
d'une nouvelle société qui est
indispensable nous le répétons dans un
plan horloger français
à votre avis est ce que l'on risque de
revivre 1973 au pourquoi or quand on
voit un peu tous les conflits qui lie à
l'heure actuelle des conflits qui durent
qui sont très longs à notre avis nous ça
sera la même chose ça sera un conflit
très dur
en tout cas on est décidés à faire tout
ce qu'il faut et on entendra encore
parler nous pendant longtemps
oui on entendra certainement encore
parler de l'ip longtemps mais pouvait-on
sauver la société et comment personne
n'a pu ou n'a su répondre à ces deux
questions avant que les grilles de la
justice ne se referme sur le sinn de
palente et il faut bien le constater que
le rideau tombe sur la sphère l'ip en
tout cas une certaine affaire l'ip car
rien en tout cas ne peut plus être comme
avant la liquidation des biens c'est le
scénario classique et implacable des
sociétés déclarées en faillite
on vend tout et on tire un trait sur une
affaire qui n'est plus capable de régler
ses propres d'être concrètement cela va
se passer ainsi ces jours ci les
employés et les cadres vont recevoir
leur lettre de licenciement
ils auront droit pendant un an au
chômage économique à leurs indemnités
aux congés payés bref à tout ce qui leur
est dû et qui leur sera réglé dans le
mois paraît-il dans le mois qui vient
avec l'argent que les deux syndic nommé
par le tribunal auront dégagés vendant
les biens de lit car on va essayer de
vendre tout ce qui est possible les
machines les bâtiments la marque même et
les brevets qui intéresse toujours la
société suisse et bouche avec ce qui
restera on tentera de rembourser dans
l'eure
la sécurité sociale et l'état et s'il ya
encore de l'argent les banques les
créanciers les fournisseurs les
actionnaires restent ce que charles
piaget vient de réaffirmer vous l'avez
entendu les 900 lips battrons jusqu'au
bout
mais peut-on vraiment se battre contre
le néant d'un côté et la justice de
l'autre
pour françois mitterrand si la gauche
gagne les élections dans deux ans le
président de la république devra faire
appel un premier ministre de gauche
jusqu'ici rien de révolutionnaire pour
georges marchais en cas de victoire de
la gauche le président devra se
soumettre ou se démettre se soumettre au
verdict des électeurs
le ton est déjà plus âpre pour jean
lecanuet les propos de georges marchais
signifie que la gauche veut le départ de
valéry giscard d'estaing et qu'elle
exigera encore deux victoires on entre
là dans la polémique électorale
mais alors qu'en pensent ceux qui se
place volontairement entre la majorité
et le programme commun de la gauche ils
ne sont pas encore nombreux certes mais
après tout la valeur d'un avis ne se
mesure pas à l'importance des effectifs
qui soutiennent celui qui l'émet ainsi
du sénateur henri caillavet qui a quitté
les radicaux de gauche parce que
l'alliance avec les communistes le
mettait mal à l'aise sa conception de la
dualité des pouvoirs dans notre pays va
vous allez vous en rendre compte assez
loin oui c'est un problème que
j'évoquais dans un ouvrage et qui paraît
actuellement les coudées franches
je suis partisan d'un scrutin
présidentiel c'est à dire d'un régime
qui tend à privilégier le président et
que devient le parlement le nom le
parlement dans un régime semblable aux
confrères auraient des droits
considérable puisqu'il aurait des droits
de contrôle et le président serait
maître de la politique française
ce qu'il est d'ailleurs en fait
seulement aujourd'hui il ya un désaccord
entre le droit et le fait nous sommes
aux régimes qui laisse supposer que le
système est de type parlementaire alors
qu'il est déjà dans leur présidence et
liszt en d'autres termes votre remède à
vous c'est de faire coïncider dans le
temps l'élection du président de la
république et l'élection du parlement
oui il se ferait qu'à ce moment là dans
un régime présidentiel
les parlementaires qui se réclamerait du
président se ferait élire en même temps
que le président haut ce qui serait
l'adversaire
les adversaires du président en afrique
se ferait élire contre lui il y aurait
donc si vous voulez
adéquation entre la majorité
parlementaire et la majorité
présidentielle il n'y aurait pas de
conflit
alors qu'aujourd'hui nous posons la
question si demain l'opposition gagne
des élections commencera appliquer la
constitution
oui mais ce que dans ce cas là vous vous
présidentialiser patrol régime
je crois que de plus en plus nous sommes
obligés de présidentialiser le régime
car les français les démocraties
modernes sont attachés à l'efficacité
c'est à dire donc à une équipe de
dirigeants de manager et on traitera de
la politique comme on traite des grandes
aventures de la démocratie elle risque
de personnalisation du pouvoir ne
passait groupe ac actuellement le
pouvoir le soin personnalisé des égards
exceptionnelle pour le président
ivoirien houphouët boigny en visite
officielle à paris pour monsieur giscard
d'estaing la chaleur de l'accueil
illustre une politique africaine qui
tient en une phrase il faut enlever du
concept de coopération la notion
d'impérialisme sous toutes ses formes
samedi prochain c'est vers l'armé que le
chef de l'état va se tourner comme il
l'a déjà fait au plateau d'albion ou ici
à orange
monsieur giscard d'estaing va rendre
visite aux militaires chez eux cette
fois pour le 8 mai jour anniversaire
il sera quoiqu'il en chef d'état syrien
dans les universités situation est
encore confuse mais avec tendance à la
reprise
certaines comme l'huile ont repris
presque normalement les cours d'autres
licenciés ou vincennes sont toujours en
grève dans la plupart les étudiants sont
partagés avec l'approché des examens le
retour progressif à la normale est
probable
hold up important ce matin la gare saint
charles de marseille plus de 66 millions
anciens emporté par trois hommes armés
c'était la recette de la sncf ce qui
étonne dans cette agression
la précision les renseignements dont
disposaient les malfaiteurs nous voici
maintenant de retour en italie en italie
où se dérouleront le 20 juin je vous le
disais en ouvrant ce journal les
élections législatives qui pourraient
déboucher sur une victoire du parti
communiste et l'arrivée des communistes
au pouvoir
cette perspective effraie bien des gens
non seulement dans la péninsule mais
aussi à l'étranger en particulier dans
les directions des firmes
multinationales qui ont des filiales en
italie
la chute de la lyre n'est d'ailleurs pas
étrangère aux manoeuvres de ceux qui
s'attendent à la disparition d'une
italie libera comparé à cette panique
combien mesure est presque sereine
apparaît l'attitude de l'un des plus
grands industriels italiens et aussi
européens
umberto ier le vice-président de fiat
que claude ganne hier en exclusivité
pour antenne 2 vient d'ailleurs
d'interview est-ce que vous partager
l'opinion de monsieur giovanni agnelli
votre frère et selon laquelle il ne faut
pas être pris de panique devant la
montée des communistes en italie
absolument je crois que la panique est
toujours une réaction négative
en plus je crois que la panique
aujourd'hui démontrée sur une réalité
qui existe en italie c'est à dire le
pouvoir des communistes en italie ne
peut que renforcer la panique par les
noms
ministre ne peut que renforcer les
communistes dans les prochaines
élections
est ce que fiat peut craindre un pouvoir
communiste
je vous dirai si on tient compte de ce
qu'ils sont les déclarations des
communistes la campagne électorale en 75
ne sont pas encore commencés l'actuelle
campagne électorale c'est certainement
une campagne dans lesquelles il se
déclare comme des gens prêts à accepter
le pluralisme l'entreprise privée la
démocratie si on doit tenir compte
c'est à dire des raisons pour lesquelles
ils ont obtenu ces deux augmentation de
2 2 voies en 75 et ils auront
probablement c'est une confirmation
maintenant on doit rien klein de ce
qu'on doit craindre c'est comment s'il
arrive à des positions de pouvoir plus
rapprochées de celles qu'ils ont
aujourd'hui comment ils seront capables
de gérer une situation difficile comme
la situation italienne sont se reprendre
au
aux modèles qui sont typiques de la
gestion communiste
vraiment on gouverne on doit faire des
choix et ce qu'ils sont capables de
faire les choix dans la direction dans
laquelle ils ont fait leur campagne
électorale
moi je pense que oui j'espère que oui
dans nos sens que c'est la seule façon
dans laquelle on peut voir une
modernisation et une et un avancement de
notre pays dans un système que nous
considérons qu est le système qui est le
plus apte à rendre la vie acceptable à
tout le monde qui est le système de la
liberté de la du pluralisme et de
l'acceptation des de l'acceptation du
doigt individuel précisément en tant
qu'industriels et peut-être le plus
important d'italie
si les communistes mais au pouvoir sur
quoi feriez-vous peut-être porter les
pressions car j'imagine qu'ils livraient
affrontement entre le patronat les
intérêts des industriels et le parti
communiste disant une des gardes
faiblesse ou l'italie c'est un manque de
professionnalisme je demanderai à
n'importe qui viendrait gouverner
l'italie de faire attention à une
professionnalité accrue dans la gestion
de la sphère publique
que ce soit les communistes où que ce
soit les démocrates-chrétiens deuxième
je leur demanderai d'accepter
l'entreprise comme réalité importante
pour le développement du pays et la
position des dirigeants des
entrepreneurs comme des hommes libres
dans un pays libre
ce qui me fait peur c'est toujours une
soumission à l'autorité politique au
delà de ce qui est convenable pour une
bonne gestion de l'affairé industriel
vous fait une différence entre une
gestion communiste d'une ville et puis
la gestion au niveau de l'état via une
énorme différence au niveau d'une ville
en approche les problèmes de la ville
celle ci les problèmes pratiques de tous
les jours dans une gestion de l'état
c'est quand même ce sens ce sont les
grandes voies vers lesquels le pays va
en a toutes les options politiques on a
tous les choix politiques cogestion du
globe
alors en ce moment l'italie est dans une
crise politique grave
et est-ce que sur le plan d'économies
cette crise politique a des
répercussions graves aussi est ce que
l'économie italienne mais pas
aujourd'hui au port de la catastrophe
l'économie italienne est certainement
dans les thèmes très très mauvaises
conditions au moment actuel
mais ce sont des conditions qui ne me
font pas une peur énorme ce que je dirai
que la plus grande faiblesse l'italie
aujourd'hui c'est un manque de
productivité et un manque de
productivité dans des pourcentages qui
ne sont pas n 10 15% augmenter la
productivité de 10 à 15% dans un pays
comme l'italie ne demande pas des grands
sacrifices mais il faut la crédibilité
de ceux qui le demandent si nous
arrivons à avoir effectivement une
situation politique qui a de la
crédibilité et qui arrive à demander des
sacrifices même assez petit je crois que
la situation économique dans le tournoi
de 18 mois peut se remettre dans des
positions acceptable
c'est finalement une journée pour rien
aux assises d'avenir les révélations que
prétendait faire un cambiste air
emprisonné à angers ont tourné court
pierre goldman connaîtra la décision des
jurés demain soir il a quand même un
point à élucider au moins pourquoi ce
gangster albert bin der at il voulu
venir déposer devant la cour d'assises
personne ne saura sans doute jamais
quelles étaient les motivations précises
d'albert bin der truand aux épaules
étroites et au visage creusé personnages
étranges vivant dans le mythe de son
rôle de gangster loyal envers un ami
caractère dont il serait intéressant de
chercher le fond si le dossier n'était
pas aussi mystérieux d'abord bender n'a
pas voulu finalement donné l'identité
dicks de le dénonciateur de goldman et à
vrai dire on peut douter maintenant
qu'ils la connaissent par contre il a
désigné un homme qui a pris silhouette
de zombies c'est bernard martin at il
dit le meurtrier les deux pharmaciennes
je le sais il me l'a dit en 73 je
l'avais retrouvé pour innocenter goldman
et pendant quelques instants
bin der appris à jouer au malfrat
régulier à l'homme qui veut que chacun
paie l'addition qu'il a consommé
puis est venue du staff jobard directeur
adjoint de la police jeudi
hier large et calme comme une armoire
normande bernard martin il dit en
s'appuyant sur la barre a été condamné à
mort par contumace en 69 et en 71
on ne l'avait jamais revu depuis 63 nous
nous sommes persuadés qu'il est mort le
policier a ajouté
pour ces mêmes affaires de règlements de
comptes bernard marc albert d'under plus
tôt a été condamné à 10 ans de réclusion
puis une petite phrase qui est peut être
la clé de la motivation de la démarche
d'albert bin der baader a été identifié
autrefois grâce à une voiture qui
appartenait à bernard martin sous
entendu bader rejette peut-être sur
martin la responsabilité de son
arrestation voilà fermé ce qui n'était
finalement qu'une parenthèse ni l'avocat
général jacques basse ni pierre goldman
n'avait intérêt à ce qu'elle soit
ouverte
le procès continue l'aude l'attend aussi
avec demain le réquisitoire les
plaidoiries et surtout le verdict c'est
à dire le poids de la conscience des
jurés damien le temps il a fait beau
près de la méditerranée avec des
températures atteignant 21 degrés tandis
que sur le reste de la france le ciel
était souvent très nuageux et par
moments plus vieux avec des températures
comprises entre 9 et 15 degrés peut-être
avez-vous remarqué quand même que le
vent a changé de direction
demain il fera encore assez beau dans le
midi et le sud ouest le ciel sera par
contre couvert avec quelques pluies du
sud de la bretagne et de la vendée au
jura et au nord des alpes et je connais
beaucoup d'agriculteurs qui s'en
réjouiront au nord de cette zone une
lente amélioration se développera et le
ciel sera variable avec des éclaircies
et du soleil mais les températures
marqueront une légère baisse ce soir
après
la tête et les jambes je n'ai peut-être
excusez moi la tête et les jambes et
l'émission d'alain decaux vous
retrouverez gérard holtz qui vous
présentera la dernière édition de notre
journal
bonne soirée sur antenne 2 à demain